hey guys you're probably wondering am i
dead funny you should ask that question
anyway we're filming a special video
here in the middle of nowhere and we're
suing it's funny I have almost no
internet here so the video that you're
seeing had to be uploaded for like an
hour
and it's only like a minute long so I'll
be quick this is the more time I take
here Lloyd so this is a cool limited
edition notebook and this and this is a
cool limited edition shirt we're raising
money for charity check out the charity
down in the description below
and check out the merch page for these
items there's also a water bottle with a
pen if you're looking for this video
that we're filming it's not going to be
ready for a long time because we need
many many many many days to film it
we're probably gonna have to do it over
the course of I don't know many weeks so
it's a really cool project but and I had
videos planned but I can't upload them
because we got no internet here and if I
was to drive an hour out just to upload
a video we wouldn't be able to come back
and film it makes sense alright I gotta
go because this is gonna take forever to
upload anyway